citizens of the reject Nation we got
ourselves an official trailer for Dune
two John number four how are you I'm
good I'm all spiced up and ready to go
how are you g be careful we gotta be
mindful of the censorship YouTube is one
of those days we can't talk about the
science fiction spice and taking it or
else it might sound suggestive I don't
want to suggest I have the ability to
chart plots through space and time thank
you for being mindful ladies and
gentlemen if you're excited for Dune two
leave a like on this video
um
fear is never any killer ladies and
gentlemen before we go to this trailer I
have to give a massive massive thank you
to everyone who has already bought
tickets we have sold a bunch for the
event that I am doing with John campia
and Christian harloff this coming Sunday
May 7th at five o'clock P.M Flappers
comedy in Burbank so many of you ever
bought tickets already see a couple
months back we United to do a live show
in honor of Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania talked about it but mainly
we got to interact with fans who were
there during the show and after the show
it was one of the best moments of my
YouTube career so we thought we'd do it
again for Gardens the Galaxy Vol 3. it's
a movie that all three of us really
loved so I'm excited to be talking about
excited to meet all of you who are going
to be there if you can come in person we
still got some tickets available that
would be amazing to have you there but
if you can't come in person we also have
pay-per-view links as well so anywhere
from around the world come and watch
thank you guys so much again there's
links in the description box and pin
comment let's see this trailer for don't
dos
breathtaking
these iMac shots
if you dive in you can't reach the
bottle you dive in yes it's called
swimming I don't I don't believe you
crazy kids in the shadows of arracus lie
many secrets
is that Florence
lady Jessica in the pod
it's a good line
the end of House of treaties the father
didn't believe in Revenge
[Music]
what if parallel treaties were still
alive yeah
[Music]
oh she's spiced up have you ever had a
dream about your first ride
don't try to impress anyone
ride that worm do we we don't know that
these simple
God damn wow
nothing fancy I understand
[Laughter]
ride the worm
yes
come what deep
[Music]
hello
God butcher
[Music]
we gave them something to hope for
that's not home oh she upgraded man
with a knife chip and shatter
oh damn man
rise to your mantle
[Music]
wow what a beautiful trailer I heard
this whole thing you shot an iMac that's
the entire thing is Sean and IMAX I saw
the first one at a regular theater uh
second one on on Dolby and then the
third one on on real IMAX and I'm a IMAX
Enthusiast this was one of the most
beautiful movies I've seen on IMAX to
see that this is going to be entirely
filmed on IMAX and to have this like
all-out War vibe to it I'm very very
very excited for it because I remember
like the for when the first trailer for
the last one came out and people who
weren't familiar with the book
I was really under the impression like
they're trying to like advertise the
action in this trailer but it's probably
gonna be like a real slow dreddy kind of
movie and then it came out and that's
what it was for the most part I mean
it's still gorgeous and beautiful but I
and I love the hell out of the movie I
thought it was amazing this one I I
really feel like we're gonna get a lot
of great action as well uh it just seems
like so many of the sequences of what we
were building upon from the last one to
hear the rise of Paula tradies and uh I
like to call them the fry man that's
right I have my ways of remembering them
the Benny and the Jets this is what I
call the better Jets
that's great the Kiwi hash browns is the
quizzots the hadoukens is what I call
them yeah definitely so I'm like this
that's how you get there
I think the most impressive things that
I I think can easily be taking for
granted is the fact that they did shoot
this later they didn't shoot this back
to back but it is meant to be treated as
one gigantic film this feels like it was
shot back to back just from the way
everyone looks like this doesn't look at
all that there was a gap in filming yeah
it really does look cohesive which is
interesting too because uh Denny
Villeneuve I think said he wanted to use
like all new stuff and new locations and
new everything for this movie and and
two he kind of echoed that sentiment
that you just brought up which is the
first movie being much more of a
contemplative building experience than
this being sort of a more Epic War Story
I mean that definitely communicates from
this trailer and I just love the way
that yeah you have the growth of the
Paula tradies story you know rising to
lead these people out of uh the desert
basically out of their relegation
they're called fry men's the fry the fry
guys
but two just to look at the new
characters too and I like I love the
take on fade rotha here because I think
a lot of people just know the The Sting
with his wild hair and his little gold
diaper to have Austin Butler to have
Elvis now Ascend to this role and be
sort of like the anti-politrates I think
is a really fun thing and and a sort of
like complete opposite from what you're
expecting of Austin Butler at this exact
moment and then Florence Pew too is a
great choice uh I think for lady erolon
and I'm curious to see how they attack
that part of the story because in the
book she isn't really a care like she
shows up at one point she doesn't really
speak aside from like these little
asides that open up every chapter with
historical context so it seems like they
have a lot of room to you know did you
actually finish the book
I'm pretty close and yeah every chapter
opens up with a piece of context to the
overall story delivered by her it's
almost like you're reading a history
compiled by her character and so uh
they're gonna have to take some creative
license in realizing her here she's
already got more dialogue I think than
she does in the book and uh and I wonder
if they'll show like you know sort of
the ruling home world and I think
Christopher Walken's her Dad too so like
that's gonna become a pretty important
you know side of the story
it's not Chinese what do you want
to my daughter
Austin Butler is the brother of the Dave
Bautista character so I'm I'm very
curious to see how they interact and and
you know what their chemistry becomes
like if they have much of it in the
story I mean well there was such a build
up to Dave Bautista as well uh from the
last movie and we we don't see a ton of
him here but I thought he'd be a little
more prevalent obviously Josh Brolin is
back which is exciting to see that he is
able to survive this looks like he's
lived quite a life since then you know
you also have Rebecca Ferguson lady
Jessica gosh that's an easy name to
remember uh lady Jessica who looks like
she got a Benny and the Jets upgrade oh
she has ascended herself she's been on
that spice boy I mean what is she trying
to get high up with the bed of jestery
trying to attend more power don't tell
me don't ruin it
yeah I mean at very least she's trying
to gain that sight that allows you to
see through time and plot you know
charts through the Galaxy and there was
one shot in here where it was kind of
reminding me of uh because in the last
movie Paul had to fight with the knife
uh the knife fight with the fremin and
then yeah it looked like he was going to
shed was that was he gonna show down
with with Austin Butler yeah I think so
he and uh fade Ralph uh because because
fade Ralph is set up to be like the
harkonan version of Paul basically he's
just like the anti-paul oh gosh so he's
just this like vile opportunistic figure
who yeah probably will have to duel with
him before the movie is out I love it I
love to see it it all looks fantastic
and we're actually gonna get more
Zendaya of course because I remember
when the the second time I watched it
when they finally got to Zendaya towards
the end of the movie there was like one
person in the audience who just screamed
they went finally like because they
advertised her all over the trailer and
then she barely was in the movie yeah
but we're obviously going to get a lot
more of her uh but yeah I'm excited for
it guys what did you think about this
Dune dose trailer leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like and hey uh before we go thank you
again for uh everyone who bought tickets
ready for the show listens to the patron
of the day shout out
Tyler Hague Tyler if you were a sand
worm I would love to ride you through
the desert I feel like we would have
some great travels getting through all
that dirt and also being able to cuddle
up with you when it gets too cold at
night discovering all kinds of Hidden
Treasures primarily spice we could find
together oh man you and I on spice
together we would have a ball of a Time
the kind of visions and love making we
would ultimately end up doing and not
remembering in the morning would be well
worth it Tyler you know it would be
worth it
anyway
you know what do I really need to say
more man you're perfect
I can't wait to ride you in the desert
my friend get that worm boy get that
quiz that's Tyler Rock
[Music]